well the water authority board met today
to discuss new regulations to help with
our water shortage sally jaramillo is
live near silverado ranch and decatur to
tell us what changes are in store for
the future sally
according to the southern nevada
southern nevada
water authority turf uses the most
amount of water so as new developments
are being built in the las vegas valley
you won't see a lot of green unless it's
artificial there are some exceptions
though schools parks and cemeteries
this year there were some more
significant changes than usual in
particular the colorado river being in
drought colby pellegrino is the deputy
manager of resources for the southern
nevada water authority she says due to
the first declare shortage as well as
big shift in the population projections
for our community there is a need for a
new water conservation goal so our
current water conservation goal is 105
gallons per capita per day so
if we take all the water use in the
valley divided by the number of people
that live here that's how we come up
with gallons per capita per day we're
proposing lowering that from 105 gallons
per capita per day to 86. on monday the
southern nevada water board adopted two
resolutions in support of that new goal
the first being a limitation on turf the
second restrictions on the installation
of evaporative cooling also known as
swamp coolers and we've also adopted
ab356 which requires non-functional turf
outside of the single family sector to
be removed by 2027 but there's still
work to be done the colorado river
supplies 90 percent of the water to this
community so it's vitally important that
we
do the right thing and manage our water
resources responsibly we live in a
desert we should act like it
back out live another recommendation on
water conservation you want to change
that irrigation timer when recommended
throughout the throughout the year for
now reporting live in the southwest part
of the valley sally jaramillo live local
now